ABBY CAREY: Hi.
I'm Abby, and this
is a quick look
at how Cloud Code makes getting
started with Secret Manager
easy.
Hard-coding sensitive
configuration data,
like database passwords
at API keys into strings,
is usually not a good
idea for your code base.
Secret Manager securely
stores this sensitive data
in Secrets, a project
global object that's
available to your application
at build or runtime.
Cloud Code makes
it easy to replace
sensitive data in your
code base with Secrets
that are stored securely
on Google Cloud with Secret
Manager.
You can create and
integrate Secrets
without leaving your IDE, no
matter what type of application
you're creating.
Cloud Code is available for
JetBrains IDEs, VS code,
and Cloud Shell Editor.
I'm going to run
this demo in PyCharm.
When you run your service
in one of our environments,
we make it easy for
you to add Secrets,
whether you're
running it locally
or remotely on Google Cloud.
To start, I've created a
Python Flask, Cloud Run
service with one of
Cloud Code's samples.
It's a simple hello,
world example.
I've enabled the Secret
Manager API for my GCP project,
added the Secret Manager library
to my requirements.txt file,
and coded up an extra function
that returns the latest version
value of the Secret.
All the Secret Manager actions
happen in the Secret Manager
panel.
From here, you can view a
project's existing Secrets
and create new Secrets.
To create a Secret,
click the Add button
and provide a name and value.
Now that my Secret
has been created,
it shows up in the
Secret Manager panel.
To view the value of your Secret
version, go to the version tab,
right-click a version, and
select View Secret Value.
To access this Secret's latest
version value from my service,
I'm going to replace
this message with a call
to the access Secret
version function I added.
In my Secret Manager panel,
I can right-click a Secret
and get its Secret ID, and then
stick it in the parameters.
Now it's time to
see if this works.
I'll run my service locally
on Cloud Code's Cloud Run
emulator.
Check the link in the
description with info
on how to do this.
Setup only takes a second.
For local development,
accessing this Secret
from Cloud Code's Cloud Run
emulator automatically works.
No need to worry
about authentication.
And there we have it, the
contents of my Secret.
I can also create a new
version of my Secret
by right-clicking it and
selecting New Version.
Since the function I added
grabs the latest Secret version
by default, I can
refresh my service
and see my new Secret value.
That's a quick look at Cloud
Code's Secret Manager support.
If you have any questions or
feature requests about Cloud
Code, join our Slack channel.